how's it going guys welcome back to a
video on co tech materials today I'm
going to still a little update on this
ancient Archer game engine game thing
I've been working on and as it says here
it's a work in progress 3d scripting
game engine built on C++ it's it's my
own little personal project and this is
the I think sixth vlog and it might be
the last one in a while as I'll explain
so it's been a while since I've done one
of these and I've basically been working
on getting some new lighting going and
potentially other rendering systems like
Vulcan and I've thought about also doing
more with the rendering too so there's a
lot going on right now is what it comes
down to and I'm a bit overwhelmed
working on this and I haven't had as
much time as I usually have being that
kids are out of school I've probably
only spent about half the usual time on
this in the last couple weeks and I
think I'm going to learn some stuff on
unreal for a while and then come back to
this but this is still private as you
can see I want to make a few final
little changes here mainly just
straighten out the lighter the lighting
but currently the only rendering this
does is on OpenGL so since that's being
depreciated I've got to update all that
rendering stuff and update all the
shaders now I'm not a shader guru and
this is what he eats a lot of my time is
trying to get all the shaders right so
that's been a bit of a struggle like I
can handle the logic and structuring
things but when it comes to setting up
all the shaders and putting in all the
math lighting the math for the lighting
it it can be a little overwhelming at
times and also getting your loader
correctly seems to be pretty pretty
crucial to
so I have this little file we're loading
for OpenGL and yeah it has to match with
the shaders and so that's basically
where I am I'll do a quick run on the
thing just to kind of show you where
it's at let's see here you know I you
know I have no shortage of ideas and
things to do it's all about not
spreading myself too thin and execution
how well I can do in any of these and
yeah I think I'm spreading myself too
thin so that's one of the reasons I
gotta make some choices here to put
things on hold or not and what to focus
on but this is what it looks like we're
on the on some test yeah I'm on some
test branch I'm not on the master
development I think I'm a lighting test
there's a lot of changes that I haven't
even committed here and right now I
think someone's messed up with the
shaders so it doesn't show the textures
right so I need to at least fix that
let's see what does a still urgent
engine and I was also looking at Dilla
'td dilligent engine as you may have
seen from my last video and considering
using its rendering system and then
wrapping it up in my world logic and
windowing system so that's another thing
in the pipeline potentially another
option
alright see so what did I do last I've
just been kind of updating things and I
fixed some mouse issues and updated the
controls and window handle handling so
the thing I'm actually most proud of is
this right now is the window handling
and the way the controls can be
integrated in pretty easily and yeah
sound effects obviously work that one in
there for a wool fireball thing but this
is showing a shader error error because
it's in debug and it's just yeah it's
not loading the shader stuff right this
that's why these look this way these are
just randomly placed within this
occasion that you see I mean within and
I could arbitrarily do anything with any
object but yeah here I'm just testing
some shader stuff apparently where I
left off well there's not a whole lot
else to say about this other than it's a
big in progress thing and I do want to
just go ahead and make it public and let
it sit there for a while while I work on
unreal
so I think a good choice for me would be
to do that because I'm sort of at a
point where I just look at everything in
my engine and I can do this for hours
just look at everything and do like a
bunch of little changes but make no real
progress so I think I need to step back
and look at bigger picture that way I
can get an idea of exactly what I need
to fix and focus on so I might come back
in a month or two and start focusing on
this engine again but after this vlog
and a few last pending changes it is
going on the bench for a while as I'm
gonna focus on learning unreal and get
as many takeaways as I can from that and
in that process I think that I can
improve ancient or in the long run cuz
what it comes down to is I just need to
use other game engines I'm I've always
not used game engines so even when I was
doing my computer courses in computer
science courses in school throughout
that whole time we were like more
instructed how to write our own stuff
using engines and stuff was not really
allowed in any of the projects so
yeah I've never really made a game with
an engine before I've made a couple
little games with my own code and I
think I really want to just dig in an RT
since I've been digging in and learning
stuff I've kind of learned what they
separate and what it and what should be
kind of presented to the user or not or
just handled so those are things that I
will probably incorporate into this
engine at a later time into my ancient
archery game as you know I should also
say that this didn't start out as a game
as an engine it was actually like this
little project for school maybe I've
said this before in other videos I'm not
sure but after I finished the project I
kept kind of just working on it and
realizing that I could build a system
around this and it's changed many times
since then but yeah that's kind of how
it all started and I just started
calling a game engine because I wanted
to be able to make arbitrarily any game
with it but yeah cuz that's where it's
at so I might give it a different name
when it actually releases - I haven't
decided on that but I've considered it
ancient Archer I don't know about that
name be nice if I could get like a
proper archery demo going then maybe I'd
be happy with the name right now the
physics is not really in there I haven't
really got a chance to focus on that at
all I've been messing with other stuff
so yeah that's it all right think I've
rambled on enough let me know what you
guys think and look forward to some more
videos I might do some unreal tutorials
some some basics that'll help you get
started things that helped me and peace
out guys stay safe out there don't catch
the thing stay inside stay in your home
all that anyway peace out you gotta go
help open something